they're gonna buy every single family
home in America the wef telling us
that we will own nothing and be happy
could that be happening right at this
very moment uh well here's RFK Jr again
explaining what's happening uh with
housing right now in America
you're paying maybe three percent
interest now you're paying a seven
percent interest
the house is three or four or five times
expensive and there's no way and then
what everybody has this experience of
knowing somebody who is about to buy a
house and then somebody comes in just
before they go into escrow
somebody comes in with a cash offer and
snatches out from under them and this
this is just now a ubiquitous experience
and what's happening is not only are we
aren't we you know suffering inflation
from the constant Wars eight trillion
dollars on War
eight trillion dollars that we didn't
have on regime change Wars since 2002.
or also
um you have these three giant companies
BlackRock State Street in Vanguard who
own who all own each other you know
BlackRock has 10 trillion dollars these
are all private Equity companies yeah
the biggest companies in the world and
they and they are they own
I think they own uh 88 of the S P 500
those three companies say on 88 of the S
P 500 so they already own everything and
now they've decided
they're going to buy every single family
home in America so
um they're on track Now to control to
own the corporate control of the 60 of
the of the single-family homes in
America within six years so so you're
saying so when somebody comes in with a
cash offer it's it's usually from uh
it's an LLC with some ambiguous name a
shell Corp right and if you if you
follow the you know the breadcrumbs
it'll go back to
Vanguard State Street okay so really
think about this for a second they're
telling us and have been telling us for
years you will owe nothing and be happy
now think about what's going on with
interest rates right now so before Biden
during the Trump years and even before
that we and after the housing bubble
like we had a nice I don't know about a
decade of extremely low interest rates
and what happens when there are low
interest rates when you can borrow money
cheaply let's say a 2 or 2.5 percent
well then you can put say 20 down on a
house and you pay just a little bit of
interest each month and then in essence
and I I really like this when I've
bought houses over the years I kind of
like paying my mortgage because when you
have a low interest rate in essence
you're paying yourself every month that
money is going back into your house and
you're paying the bank a little
something for the the honor the favor of
lending you with the money now the banks
have gone from 2.5 3 interest rates now
we have interest rates that are around
nine percent so the average person now
if every month you have to pay nine
percent on that mortgage now you're
paying an awful lot and suddenly you
can't get that mortgage you can't buy
that house and then what happens you
have to end up renting renting you're
getting no equity you're not Building
Wealth over time owning something owning
a house or owning a car but owning
property really
it's one of the real things that I that
I think I did right in my life
financially to get things in order like
owning a house oh I own a physical thing
and I'm paying myself every month but
now if you're the average person you
can't do that and so you can see the
connection between oh if the banks raise
interest rates high enough the average
person is like I can't take out the loan
because otherwise I'm just paying the
bank every month it's a crazy amount of
money and then BlackRock and Vanguard
and these other companies come in with
these shell companies these llc's that
are kind of you just don't know who they
are and they just buy the house for cash
and now why would they buy the house or
cash either they sit there and they let
it be empty which happens or they then
allow it to be rented now there's
nothing wrong with renting in and of
itself we've all rented and at the early
part of your life renting before you've
accumulated a little cash is fine but it
sort of if you always stay as a renter
you can kind of never get into the game
so you see how the banks are connected
to exactly what BlackRock is doing